[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je traînais la honte à travers ce monde
d'avoir été et la douleur de
Déjà sous l'aile
chapeau combien de fois
étouffé, une larme est apparue, je ne pouvais pas
contenir si je traversais les routes comme
un couple sur lequel le destin a insisté
annuler si j'étais paresseux si j'étais aveugle seul
je veux aujourd'hui
comprendre la valeur que représente
courage de
[Musique]
Je voulais toute ma vie comme un soleil
du printemps mon espoir et mon
passion
Je savais que le monde ne convenait pas à tous
humble joie de mon pauvre cœur
[Musique]
maintenant je suis assis bas dans mon trajet
Je ne peux pas dépasser les illusions
démarrer
Je rêve du passé
[Musique]
ajouté le bon vieux temps où je pleure et que
jamais
[Musique]
pour suivre ses traces j'ai bu
inlassablement ma tasse
mais personne
J'ai compris que si je donnais tout
chaque tour laissait un morceau de
le cœur maintenant triste la pente
Solitaire déjà vaincu, je m'aime
[Musique]
avoue si cette bouche mentait
qui me
J'ai offert pour ces yeux Bros non
abrasé
toujours
[Musique]
plus loin
toute la vie pour moi comme un
soleil de printemps, mon espoir et mon
passion
Je savais que le monde ne convenait pas à tous
humble joie de mes pauvres
coeur
Maintenant je me lance dans ma balade
Je ne peux pas dépasser les illusions
démarrer
[Musique]
c'est pour le passé ça
Fini le bon vieux temps où je pleurais et ça
jamais
[Musique]
revenir
Oh